lyne lafontaine et michel jacobs craque
pour un crb lors d'une vente privée chez
leur concessionnaire honda de laval le
vendeur est pétri klein parce que des
frais encourus
non ils retournent donc leur civique 15
mois avant la fin du bail de location
en échange on leur vend un servait 37
mille quatre cent cinquante dollars
selon le représentant de leur assureur
c'est beaucoup trop cher pour ce type de
véhicule le communiqué avec la
directrice des finances
elle lui a confirmé que le montant était
le banc et qu'il y avait une balle donne
la balloune c'est le transfert d'une
dette
dans ce cas si la dette est de plus de
6000 $ c'était clair et évident pour
nous deux que le vendeur nous avait
trompés
lyne lafontaine fait annuler l'offre
d'achat puis porte plainte aux
concessionnaires
j'ai même réécrit au directeur du
concessionnaire et j'ai eu aucune
réponse
à la 20' de son véhicule précédent qu'on
a mis dans le financement ne sont
nourris ont ensuite indiqué ni sur le
document ni verbalement carton
l'assureur à communiquer avec nous on
était transparent avec ça la balloune
c'est un fléau madame cet ex directeur
des ventes travaillent dans le secteur
automobile depuis une trentaine d'années
nous protégeons son identité car il est
encore dans ce domaine tous les jours
les gens cachent des ballounes ça peut
être dans le prix de l'auto ça peut être
dans des frais administratifs qui sont
astronomiques puis les gens disent rien
l'association pour la protection des
automobilistes à mener des enquêtes au
québec en alberta et en
colombie-britannique le constat ce genre
de dette cachée aux clients est très
répandue nous avons vu à la paix à des
soldes impayés des bâlois qui vont
jusqu'à 20000 dollars
le fils de la protection du consommateur
affirme qu'il était illégal de
transférer ses dettes au couple s'est
interdit de refinance soit antérieure
d'un cas d'une vente à tempérament skis
étaient aussi illégales d'après l'opc
c'est d'avoir caché la dette si une
malle compréhension m'excuse sincèrement
c'est vraiment un bris de confiance la
paix à voudrait que l'office de la
protection du consommateur fès enquête
et prennent des mesures musclées contre
les concessionnaires fautif l'opc de son
côté assurent qu'ils passent au peigne
fin les contrats de nombreux commerçants
pour déceler les pratiques illégales il
si esther normand radio canada montréal